este problema dice majo tarda tres horas
en repartir 189 periódicos en su ruta
cuál es la razón por hora nos piden la
razón por hora en la que entrega
periódicos bueno vamos a poner esta
oración en símbolos dice que tarda tres
horas lo voy a poner así tres horas
horas en repartir 189 periódicos 189
periódicos periódicos periódicos ok y lo
que nos preguntan es cuál es la razón
por hora en la que entrega periódicos
entonces lo que nos piden básicamente es
voltear esta razón vale queremos ver
cuántos periódicos por hora entrega y
volteando obtenemos que son 189
periódicos
cada tres horas entonces es cada tres
horas
horas pero esto lo podemos simplificar
tenemos 189 entre 3 el numerador es
divisible entre 3 108 es divisible entre
3 y el denominador también así que vamos
a simplificarlo para ver que queda hay
que hacer 189 entre 3 déjame hacerlo de
este lado 189 entre 3 si hacemos la
división de casita 3 cabe 6 veces en 18
6 por 3 18 restamos no queda nada
bajamos el 93 cabe tres veces en 9 nos
da 63 3 por 39 y aquí nos quedan 9 menos
9 que es 0 entonces 103 cabe exactamente
63 veces en 189 baja entonces dividiendo
189 entre 3 aquí arriba nos queda 63
y si dividimos el numerador entre un
número el denominador también hay que
dividirlo entre ese mismo número
entonces 3 entre 3 nos queda 1 muy bien
entonces esto lo podemos reescribir como
63 entre 1 periódicos periódicos
cada hora cada hora que por supuesto
también se puede escribir como 63 porque
63 entre unos 63 como 63 periódicos
periódicos
por ahora por ahora entonces esa de ahí
es la razón por hora en la que majo
entrega periódicos